you formed your own production company
this is real we were kidding around but
you really have a production I did yes
what kind of shows you want to make
really bad ones because in the soup we
run out of clips sometimes and so I'm
like we should make something to put
here for eliminate the middleman let's
not wait for clips let's just get drunk
girls in the house now
and get clips of that why is that the
secret how did this all happen where now
it's everybody has to be someone with an
alcohol dependency problem and rage
issues locked with people they don't
like in a small room a woman just
cheered for the alcoholic rage issues
she thought I was describing
Thanksgiving Oh probably a shrink it's
good for business yeah
I think that turned out to be the most
interesting part of the car crash
television that you were you know your
car accident television were you when
you just can't stop watch it because
where did it start it started with the
real world that was where it all started
yeah and and then they noticed that they
would always cast a drunk girl and a
drunk dude and then they would fight and
then that would be the most interesting
episodes and then someone was like let's
just get all drunk girls and we lock
them in a house and we'll pretend
they're supposed to do something and it
won't matter there's be drunk and it's
gonna be great for us sure we'll go to
hell but whatever
and so I feel but now this shows I mean
one of my favorite shows is bait car
which is the cops you know they put out
the bait car for people to steal and
this one guy it has cameras and cameras
in it and the cops just shut the car
down they can shut the car down and they
arrest the person and usually they are
terrified they can't believe it and this
one guy got in it if you don't close the
door then you then the car won't lock
and you can bail out so for just so you
know and this guy was excited and scream
and people like hey man but this is the
big car he's like I know I know and then
they pulled him over and the cops went
how did you know it was the bait car and
he was like I watched the show
Oh excited he was like this is my big
break and Betty's like stay tuned I'll
be on MSNBC's lockup and for 15 years
lockup extended stair just like that's
how people now are like I'm gonna get
famous this oh yeah be great I have for
years now I've done it and it's all
because of the reality television and
you probably get this too I get people
stopped me on the street no I ain't
gonna I'm gonna be on your show somebody
I'm gonna be famous and I say well you
know that's cool what do you do are you
comic you sitting here what are you
doing back I don't do anything
it's gonna blow up they'd learn to take
them seriously because it probably will
if you're if you're talentless but very
confident you're gonna have a great
career yeah there was I hate to bring
this horrible rep but when flava flav at
one point was the king of television he
like nine shows on a woman while walking
up it did all these women were competing
for the love of flava flav as we all are
right I wouldn't she just took a dump
while walking up the stairs it was an
entire episode of television and then I
was like what am I doing wrong
I am trying way too hard yeah that
episode won a Peabody and 7em here I'm
not kidding it got the Nobel Peace Prize
Daniel day-lewis will be portrayed
portraying the staircase let's clean
this show up shall we clean it up a
little bit I think so I want to mention
that community is coming back but not
returning until February right which
gets Lincoln because you've you've made
like holiday issues issues you've made
some Hardy episodes already yeah we made
well yeah we we were going to premiere
on October 19th and then we're gonna
have our Halloween episode so now we're
in February so our Halloween episode is
now our Valentine's Day episode and then
we have a Thanksgiving and Christmas
episode it'll be fine
[Laughter]